Hey, what's going on over here?
Y'all want this gun? It's stuck in the DANG ground.
- That's a glitch. Don't touch that.
- Yeah, you should let us handle that.
What, you don't  think i can carry it?
Uh, no, no, it's not that you can't handle, I just think we should handle it.
Whatever. Dibs.
No no no...
- No, man, come on, let it go already!
- I can do this!
- Screw this, I'm outta here!
- Wait! Chief!
- Chief, don't do it!
- Chief!
Wait! What's happening? Something's wrong.
Chief, got outta there!
Not like this...
- Oh, no, noooo!
- Oh, Mario!
I gotcha!
You gotta delete the game
I got you, man! Hold on! DEAD
Help me...no one will help you cuz im spaghetti
wierd glitching sounds
GAME  OVER
Players running